The fourth section is titled Experimental Conditions. A software design study
normally means running several versions of a program, making measurements, and
evaluating the results. These programs' executions take place on computers
configured with resources. Such as their number of cores, the amount of RAM,
their clock speed, and potentially net, the networking that networks them
together. To support the goal of repeatability, this configuration information
should be explicitly documented in your report. The fourth section of the design
study describes the experimental conditions under which the study is conducted.
In particular, it describes the environment of which the study will take place.
This includes elements such as the machines, [COUGH] their models,
operating systems, programming languages any virtual machines and
their versions. Where relevent, the network, the build and
execution parameters, input files, and confounding factors. Such as
other users on the machines at the same time or other, processes going on